hey guys my name is Jess I'm Dan and
it's the start of the working week and
also the side of us sunny what's going
on in gaming so be sure to stay tuned
for the next two three myths and we'll
get you caught up for those of you
looking forward to the Call of Duty
World War 2 beta later this month
sledgehammer games have released info on
what you can expect the beta which runs
from August 25 to 28 on ps4 and then
from September 1st to 4th on ps4 and
Xbox one will include at least three
Maps the three maps confirmed to be
included are point duo Ardennes and
Gibraltar on which you'll be able to
test our team deathmatch domination
hardpoint and the new war game types war
casts you as either the Allies or the
access as you battle across a scripted
map with a bunch of different objectives
as part of the beta you'll be able to
take part in operation breakout which is
described as the first war mode
experience you'll also get to try your
hand at divisions World War two's new
customization system that lets you pick
a specialist and build them up from the
infantry expeditionary airborne armored
and mountain division's if all of that
sounds like something you're interested
in checking out you can get into the
private beta by pre-ordering for taking
part you'll also get a helmet emblem and
calling card for the full game when it's
released on November 7 let us know what
you think about this one below and if
you'll be taking part so we can all try
and play together
hey den do you want to do an intro to
this story that is very long and
convoluted and doesn't really have
anything to do with it but maybe it'll
make him love sure okay how many times
have you seen the last year die trailer
none I don't watch the Star Wars
trailers because I try to keep away from
them it's like a long-term goal for me
to go into movies blind which is
something that Star Wars Battlefront 1
lacked according to the developers
he's a story in a roundtable video
released by PlayStation dice producer
Craig McLeod discuss the issues with the
first game and the common feedback they
received from fans saying a lot of
people found that with the original
battlefront
offer a few months of play they lacked
the long-term goals so these are the
things that we're really trying to make
sure we nail in this new game one of the
big additions this time around is a
single-player campaign that follows a
member of the Empire's elite Inferno
squad iDEN verso dice have also expanded
the scope of battlefront 2 to include
all areas of Star Wars something that
sorely missing from the first game and I
just want to find a boost our fighters
those things are cool look at Star Wars
Battlefront 2 will launch November 17
with a free open beta on all platforms
beginning on October 6 you may remember
that EA is bringing food for 18 -
Nintendo switch but it sounds like they
may not be stopping there that's right
if you want to be disappointed by Mass
Effect Andromeda all over again maybe
this time on the train you might be able
to do so worldwide studios VP Patrick
soderlund told edge magazine I'm a
gigantic Nintendo fanboy adding that he
brings his switch everywhere
he explained we will appear on any
platform where there are consumers and
players we believe that we want to be a
part of the switch and help Nintendo
grow that install base that's why you'll
see FIFA it's a full-fledged FIFA game
for the first time to be honest on a
portable device soderlund added that the
company may bring other games to switch
and if there is a successful more could
come later it's worth noting that FIFA
18 on switch doesn't run on the
Frostbite engine and it won't include
the games that journey campaign mode
though it's still FIFA that is
everything we've got a few today thanks
so much for joining us and do remember
to leave your thoughts on today's
stories down in that comment section Dan
you want to leave them with any pearls
of wisdom don't brush your teeth before
you drink large juice that's a good one
how many times have you seen at the last
Jedi trailer zero
I don't want sure I made mine Star Wars
trailers have this really weird rule
where I don't watch any of them and last
year when I I've completely forgotten
the story that I'm supposed to be
telling you off the caf